nos dicen que queremos resolver la
siguiente ecuación menos logaritmo
natural de 2x es igual a 2 por el valor
absoluto de x menos 4 -7 una de las
soluciones es x igual a 0.5 encuentra la
otra solución pista usa una calculadora
gráfica redondea la respuesta a la
décima más cercana pausa en el vídeo y
si quieren traten de resolverlo luego lo
resolveremos juntos aunque yo los invito
a que primero traten de resolverlo por
su cuenta vamos a resolverlo juntos la
clave aquí es darnos cuenta de que
podemos resolver esto o aproximarnos a
las soluciones de esto graficando la
forma en la que hacemos esto es que si
tenemos una ecuación especialmente una
ecuación complicada como ésta con una
variable podemos hacer que sea igual a
lo que está en el lado izquierdo y
después hacer que sea igual a lo que
está en el lado derecho y graficar ambas
funciones para después analizar en donde
se intersectan porque el valor x en
donde se intersectan
el mismo valor de g lo que significa que
ambos lados son iguales que quiero decir
con esto podemos establecer que es igual
a menos logaritmo natural de 2x ésta es
una función y podemos tener otra
ecuación o función en la que es igual a
2 por el valor absoluto de x menos 4 -7
y los valores de x en donde se
intersectan ambas se dan las soluciones
de esta ecuación voy a usar de smos como
mi calculadora gráfica vamos a escribir
a ambos lados primero el lado izquierdo
y es igual a menos logaritmo natural de
2x y voy a elegir un color que se
acerque lo más que se pueda a este color
azul la siguiente es que queremos que
sea igual a 2 pone el valor absoluto de
x menos 4 cierro el valor absoluto menos
7 y ponemos esto en color rojo para
poder ubicar las gráficas estas son mis
dos gráficas y ahora tengo que pensar en
donde se intersectan una de las
soluciones es
punto 5 como nos dicen en el enunciado
pero nos piden la otra solución veamos
cuando x es igual a 0.5 es esta solución
de aquí donde parece que es igual a 0
pero el otro punto de intersección
parece estar por acá y algo bueno que
tiene de smos es que nos indica la
coordenada exacta de un punto aquí pero
también podemos aproximar la y vemos que
está arriba de 6 y que cada uno tiene 1
2 3 4 5 cada uno de estos es punto 2 por
lo que esto está en 6.2 y algo y de
todas formas nos piden redondear a la
décima más cercana por lo que no tenemos
que usar esta característica podemos ver
claramente que cuando x es
aproximadamente igual a 6.238 tenemos
que es igual a menos 2.5 24 otra forma
de pensar en esto es que cuando x es
aproximadamente igual a 6.2 ambos lados
de esta ecuación van a ser mutuamente
iguales o aproximadamente igual
entre sí y ya terminamos acabamos de
resolver esto o nos aproximamos a la
solución
usando gráficas en una calculadora
gráfica